EtEt c'est parti pour le panel u
vevendredi avec nos collègues
SéSébastien Bovet et Daniel
ThThibault. Bonsoir. Sébastien à
MoMontréal à une vingtaine de
pipieds de moi.
- - La distanciation sociale.
- - Bien sûr. Cher Messieurs, on
vava commencer rapidement, ça
s's'impose dans l'actualité, ce
ququi est arrivé au pont de l'Î-
auaux-Tourtes ici à l'ouest de
l'l'île de Montréal. On va parlr
brbrièvement, Monsieur Bonardel
auaujourd'hui un point de presse
trtrès attendue.
FRFRANÇOIS BONNARDEL,
miministre des Transports, Québc
- - Le processus pour entamer
lele remplacement d'un pont
ouou d'une route, c'est long.
LeLe pont de l'Île-aux-Tourtes
cocoûtera entre 1 et 2 milliards
dede dollars. Mais au-delà
dede tout ça, dès mon arrivée,
j'j'ai fait du maintien d'actifs
unun leitmotiv, ça veut dire qu?
OnOn avait 20 milliards
d'd'investissements dans le PQI
enen 2018, on est rendu à
2828 milliards. Donc, je mesure
etet je comprends ce déficit
dede maintien d'actifs sur nos
roroutes, sur nos infrastructur.
C'C'est du rattrapage pour
dedes dizaines et des dizaines
d'd'années que nous avons à fai.
- - Bien voilà. Déficit de métir
d'd'actifs avec des rattrapage t
çaça coûte cher.
- - C'est drôle comment la vie
popolitique est faite. La semaie
ouoù le gouvernement annonce un
évévitement de six à 7 milliards
dede dollars qui pourraient allr
jujusqu'à 10 milliards de dollas
popour le troisième entre Québec
etet Lévis, le pont de l'Île-au-
ToTourtes doit fermer parce qu'l
y y a un bris. C'est une erreur
huhumaine. Cependant de toute
fafaçon, il faut le changer et a
ilillustre à gros traits ce famx
dédéficit d'entretien des
ininfrastructures routières au
QuQuébec. Il y en a pour des
mimilliards de dollars. C'est sr
quque ça va donner des munitions
auaux partis de l'opposition. Ns
opopposants au troisième lien
popourquoi vous voulez déposer s
mimilliards dans le troisième ln
alalors que des milliards à
dédépenser juste pour maintenir
leles actifs d'infrastructures u
QuQuébec? L'autre aspect, c'est
ququ'on pensait que la commissin
JoJohnson sur l'écrasement de
viviaduc avait sonné l'alarme pr
réréparer les viaduc et entreter
nonotre réseau routier. On
s's'aperçoit que c'est pas le c.
- - C'était quand, la commission
JoJohnson?
- - Au tournant des années 2000,
c'c'était le viaduc de la Concoe
ququi était tombée. En cours de
cocommission d'enquête, on avait
fafait fermer toutes sortes de
poponts et de viaduc parce qu'on
s's'est aperçu qu'il ne tenait
ququ'avec de la broche et il
fafallait les réparer. Ou les
chchanger. On pensait qu'on avat
apapprit nos leçons. Je n'étais
papas de gonfler l'événement qui
totouche le pont de l'Île-aux-
ToTourtes, on comprend qu'il y a
unun problème humain, une erreur
huhumaine qui s'est produite, ms
rereste que ce pont doit être
chchangé et modifié. Éclairage
fafameux déficit d'entretien des
ininfrastructures au Québec.
- - 2017 me dit-on pour la
cocommission en question. Le
dédéficit d'entretien est là. Ds
lele calcul de ce que ça va
cocoûter, on ne pourra pas compr
susur l'aide d'Ottawa parce quen
prpriorise les transports en
cocommun.
- - Voilà. Une partie du pont de
reremplacement de l'Île-aux-
ToTourtes incluait une
ininfrastructure de transport
cocollectif, on pourrait venir à
lala porte du gouvernement actu.
JeJe ne dis pas que dans le prot
gogouvernemental ne sera pas
didifférent. Les gens qui sont u
popouvoir, les libéraux, c'est e
cece côté commise. D'ailleurs
auaussi là-dessus commise. Parlr
efeffectivement de coïncidencesn
dédébut de semaine on parle du
trtroisième à Québec, ça aussi
c'c'est un problème recyquébec
sosouhaite obtenir du financemet
dudu côté d'Ottawa, ce n'est pas
cece n'est pas simple de venir à
lala porte et de demander au
gogouvernement fédéral de payer
paparti de la facture. Il n'y a
papas de volets, il n'y a pas de
grgros les transports collectif.
IlIl y en a un de voix, une voix
dede chaque e côté. Ottawa pourt
dédécider de venir mettre des ss
susur la table pour financer une
papartie, mais je suis loin d'êe
cecertain qu'on va être disposéà
papayer une grosse portion de la
fafacture qui pourrait aller
jujusqu'à 10 milliards de dolla.
OnOn verra. Pour l'instant,
j'j'écoutais cette semaine
MoMonsieur Duclos, le ministre
reresponsable, le ministre de la
cacapitale dans le coin de Québc
ququi disait : on attend d'avoir
lala demande formelle.
GoGouvernement fédéral : se ranr
dederrière la demande formelle.
DaDans un contexte de calendrier
prpréélectoral, on n'a pas envie
dede dire non tout de suite. On
veveut voir le document et voire
ququi va se passer. C'est simple
popour l'instant. Ce n'est pas
clclair que ça va pouvoir durer
cocomme ça éternellement. Ne vos
atattendez pas à ce que Ottawa
c'c'est noté pour ce dossier.
- - Ce sera intéressant en
cacampagne électorale devant le
popositionnement de tous les
paparties sur ce dossier. Et das
lala région de Québec c'est un
dodossier important avec beaucop
dede gens veulent le troisième
lilien.
- - Malgré la note salée?
- - Malgré la note salée. C'està
cecette milliard, ce sont les
ququ'on a eu au début de la
sesemaine milliards de dollars.l
y y a des opposants. Beaucoup de
gegens.
- - Les conservateurs d'être en
fafaveur du projet. On peut le
cocomprendre. Il y a quand même
papas mal de députés conservates
dadans le coin du troisième lie.
OnOn voit du côté des troupes
d'd'Erin O'Toole un potentiel de
crcroissance intéressant dans la
rérégion de Québec. Je peux
cocomprendre la position qu'on
adadopte ce côté. C'est un coutu
àà deux tranchants. Il y a de
l'l'appui dans la région de
QuQuébec, mais pas de la plupart
auau Québec pour ce projet. En
alallant dans cette direction à
QuQuébec, peut-être qu'on grève
leles chances du parti
coconservateur de faire des gais
ouou de faire bonne figure
aiailleurs. À l'est du Québec au
SaSaguenay, dans la banlieue de
MoMontréal par exemple. Il y a n
exexercice d'équilibre à
l'l'intérieur de tout ça. Je pee
quque les députés consnservateus
ququébécois vont devoir trouver
unune façon de vendre le projett
dede le défendre. Il y a une que
d'd'équilibre dans ce dossier qi
dedevra se faire. On passe
mamaintenant sur le front de la
COCOVID. Ce qui se passe à la
frfrontière. Il y a cette
ququarantaine encore obligatoirà
l'l'hôtel. C'est maintenu. La
frfrontière terrestre aussi, la
fefermeture, on écoute Monsieur
LeLeblanc et ont en reparle.
DODOMINIC LeBLANC, ministre
féfédéral, Aff.Intergouvernemen.
- - Les mesures de quarantaines
obobligatoires, pour nous, sont
esessentielles dans le contexte
acactuel. Nous reconnaissons
auau fil des prochaines semaine,
auau moment où le nombre
dede personnes vaccinées augmen.
E Et si on continue de voir
unune diminution des cas de COV,
dedes hospitalisations,
onon sera peut-être en mesure
d'd'assouplir d'une façon
prprogressive ces mesures-là.
- - Statu quo tour de table.
- - C'est très difficile
d'd'imaginer qu'Ottawa puisse
fafaire les choses différemment
auaujourd'hui. Le programme
fofonctionne. Le but, c'était de
dédécourager les Canadiens d'alr
àà l'extérieur entre autres.
S'S'assurer que s'il le faisait,
etet reven avec une facture sal.
CÇa donne le sentiment qu'on
prprotège, qu'on s'assure qu'il
n'n'y a pas de propagation masse
dede variants, de gens qui
rereviennent de destination ou
c'c'est plus compliqué, on parle
bebeaucoup Alain : d'autant plus
quque rappelez-vous, le
gogouvernement Trudeau avait été
acaccusé d'avoir traîné des pies
enen début de pandémie avec la
fefermeture de la frontière. Le
gogouvernement Ford en Ontario
crcritique le gouvernement Trudu
susur sa lenteur à limiter les
dédéplacements. Ça fait parti du
didiscours préélectoral de
MoMonsieur Ford en Ontario. Dans
cece contexte, le gouvernement
féfédéral n'a rien à gagner à de
onon met un terme aux mesures qi
nonous permet de protéger peut-
êêtre un peu les gens à leur
reretour au pays.
- - Dans le contexte n'est pas
susurprenant que le gouvernement
féfédéral décision. La pensée de
cecertaines juridictions évolue
llà-dessus. En particulier pour
leles gens qui ont reçu deux dos
dede vaccin. Qui sont pleinement
vavaccinés. Lors de leur retouru
papays. L'Union européenne par
exexemple c'est entendu sur le
fafait qu'à partir du 1er juill,
sisi tout va bien, les pays
n'n'imposeront plus de quarantae
àà des gens qui entrent sur leur
teterritoire si ces gens sont
cacapables de démontrer qu'ils t
étété vaccinés deux fois notammt
avavec deux doses de vaccin. Ily
a a une évolution dans la pensée
dadans certains endroits du mon.
CÇa ne veut pas dire que ça
ararrive tout de suite au Canad.
LeLes gens ne sont pas capablese
prprouver avec un code, tout le
momonde n'a pas son code QR, tot
lele monde n'a pas nécessairemet
lala preuve de vaccination. Et a
séséance dite aussi que deux dos
quque l'on peut toujours
trtransmettre la maladie, avoirt
lala transmettre. Mais il y a ue
évévolution dans certains endros
dudu monde sur cette question.
- - Il nous reste peu de temps
mamalheureusement. Un petit mot
susur ce débat entourant le prot
dede loi 96. Les échos que ça
sususcite un peu partout au pay.
OnOn comprend que c'est un autre
exexemple des de solitude quandn
vovoit les réactions contrastée.
- - En même temps, cette semaine
ététait surprenant d'entendre
MoMonsieur Trudeau dire : on a
coconsulté nos avocats et on pet
alaller dans cette direction.
ClClairement, on parle de discos
prpréélectoral tout à l'heure, s
lilibéraux, les conservateurs, s
nénéo-démocrate n'ont pas enviee
s's'installer, s'inscrire en fax
avavec le gouvernement du Québe.
OnOn n'a pas envie de se lancer
dadans un débat comme ça.
- - Les électroniques nous diset
auautre chose.
- - Cette semaine, les signaux
ququ'on a Bloc québécois, c'est
ququ'on va tenter de souligner a
didifférence entre ce qui se pae
cece qui se passe au Canada
ananglais avec le dépôt de Chame
dedes communes pour porter
jujustement les partis qui sont
asassis sur la clôture
prprésentement à peut-être se
cocommettre davantage. Ça va pe-
êêtre donner lieu à un débat pls
ouou un peu plus chauffé.
SéSébastien.
- - Il y a peut-être une
momobilisation qu'il va y avoire
nene suis pas collie tant que ç.
C'C'est un débat ponctuel. Cette
ququestion de la langue débat
élélectoral? Il y a des minorits
frfrancophones, la minorité
ananglophone au Québec, qui
pepeuvent sauter dans ce débat,
mamais on a été surpris à Québec
dede la réaction de Justin Trudu
etet son ouverture ont fait qu'n
popourrait modifier la
coconstitution unilatéralement u
QuQuébec.
- - Très bien. On verra bien.
GlGlobalement elle parle de pièe
tetendu ajuster Trudeau par
MoMonsieur Legault. À surveiller
rarapidement la semaine prochai.
IlIl y a cette mesure du bloc, n
susurveille.
- - Dépôt de cette motion du blc
nonormalement à la Chambre des
cocommunes. Reprise des travaux.
OnOn va surveiller attentivement
lala livraison des vaccins. C'et
popour. BioNTech ça va bien,
MoModerna, on a de la difficultà
obobtenir un calendrier précis.
CeCette semaine, on a eu
l'l'impression que les livraison
esest un peu à la baisse. Ça va
prprobablement revenir la semaie
prprochaine.
- - Vendredi prochain, le devisu
cocouvre-feu. C'est peut-être le
momoment de planifier vos petits
papartis.
RiRime avec petite partie. Restr
prprudent quand même. Même si
dédéconfinement commence la
sesemaine prochaine.
- - Très bien. Canadiens ou Mape
LeLeafs? C'est une blague. Une
pepetite prédiction.
- - On me parle en même temps. e
n'n'ai pas compris la question.
- - Canadiens ou Maple Leafs. Ls
CaCanadiens m'ont impressionné,
mamais je pense que les Maple
LeLeafs vont gagne